THE BACK OF THE NECK.
>> Sean: AND ANDREW GIULIANI
WILL TAKE ON CORRUPT ANDREW
CUOMO FOR NEW YORK GOVERNOR IN
2022.
THE FORMER SON OF RUDY GIULIANI
VOWED TO LEAD AN ECONOMIC
RECOVERY AND TURN THIS STATE
AROUND.
>> NEW YORK IS IN MY BLOOD.
I KNOW WHEN WE ARE.
WHAT WE CAN BE AND WHERE WE NEED
TO GO.
WE TELL IT LIKE IT IS AND NEVER
BACK DOWN.
IT'S TIME TO BRING NEW YORK
BACK.
>> Sean: CUOMO PUT SICK COVID
POSITIVE PATIENTS IN NURSING
HOME AND COVERED IT UP AND RAKED
IN $5 MILLION FOR A BOOK DEAL.
WE KNOW THE TRUTH.
THEY HID IT.
THEY HID IT BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T
WANT THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT TO
HAVE THE REAL NUMBERS ACCORDING
TO A WHISTLEBLOWER.
THE STATE OF NEW YORK DESERVES
BETTER.
A CONGRESSIONAL SEAT LOST.
NOW REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE FOR
GOVERNOR OF NEW YORK ANDREW
GIULIANI.
WE HAVE KNOWN EACH OTHER A LONG
TIME.
GREAT TO HAVE YOU.
IT'S A DAUNTING TASK.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
HAVING ME.
SEAN, YOU ARE RIGHT.
IT'S A DAUNTING TASK.
I THINK THE PERSON WHO IS HELPED
THE MOST IN THIS IS ANDREW
CUOMO.
NEW YORKERS, BUSINESSES, PEOPLE
ARE EDUCATING THEIR KIDS AND
PARENTS, THEY REALIZE THAT NEW
YORK IS NOT GIVING THEM THE BEST
OPTIONS WHETHER IT'S EDUCATION
OR ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT OR
WHETHER IT'S FROM A PUBLIC
SAFETY STANDPOINT.
SEAN, YOU ARE A PRIDEFUL NEW
YORKER AND IN NEW YORK YOUR
LIFE.
YOU HAVE EVER SEEN A TIME WHEN
NEW YORK STATE AND NEW YORK CITY
HAS HAD SUCH A LACK OF
LEADERSHIP?
>> Sean: I WAS BORN AND RAISED
IN NEW YORK.
I SPENT A FEW YEARS IN RHODE
ISLAND AND 5 YEARS IN CALIFORNIA
AND 2 YEARS IN ALABAMA AND 4
YEARS IN GEORGIA.
IT WAS A BIG DEAL TO COME BACK
TO DO NEWS IN THE FOX NEWS
CHANNEL 25 YEARS AGO.
I AM THINKING I AM GETTING OUT
OF HERE.
>> YEAH.
SEAN, WAIT 18 MONTHS.
RIGHT NOW I CAN SEE WHY PEOPLE
ARE LEAVING NEW YORK.
THAT'S WHY WE NEED TO WIN IN
2022.
IF WE DON'T TAKE BACK NEW YORK
IT MIGHT BE A GENERATION BEFORE
NEW YORK COMES.
>> Sean: FORGET AND REPUBLICANS
AND DEMOCRATS.
ARE WE GOING TO BRING BACK LAW
AND ORDER AND REFUND THE POLICE?
>> YES.
>> A NEW YORK CAN SCHOOL CHOICE
THE THE CORRUPTION IN ALBANY
CLEANED UP.
SPELL OUT THE AGENDA.
HOW DO YOU SAVE A STATE THIS
CORRUPT?
>> THAT'S RIGHT RIGHT.
THERE ARE THREE THINGS THAT
APPLY TO NEW YORK.
WHETHER YOU ARE RED OR BLUE.
NIGHT THE FURNACE OF ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AGAIN IN NEW YORK.
LOWER TAXES.
CREATING JOBS.
KEEP THEIR BUSINESSES IN NEW
YORK.
WE PUSH SCHOOL CHOICE FOR
PARENTS.
ANDREW CUOMO SAID HE WAS
A CHAMPION FOR SCHOOL CHOICE.
THIS LAST 212-BILLION DOLLARS
BUDGET SHOWED HE IS NO CHAMPION
FOR SCHOOL CHOICE.
DID NOTHING FOR THEM.
AND THIRD, MOST IMPORTANTLY, WE
STOP THIS WAR ON POLICE AND WE
MAKE SURE WE PROTECT THEIR
QUALIFIED IMMUNITY AND REPEAL
BAIL REFORM AND LET COPS KNOW
THAT ULTIMATELY WE KNOW THEY ARE
SOME OF THE BEST NEW YORKERS IN
OUR STATE, IN OUR CITIES.
THIS IS NOT JUST THE NEW YORK
CITY ISSUE.
WE KNOW THAT NEW YORK CITY HAS
SEEN A SPIKE IN VIOLENT CRIME
OVER THE LAST YEAR THAT DOUBLED.
THIS IS ALL OVER THE STATE.
SEAN, YOU WAIT UNTIL 2023.
WE WILL HAVE A NICE BIG PARTY IN
ALBANY.
>> Sean: OKAY.
YOU WILL BE ASKED IN EVERY
INTERVIEW ABOUT LEGALIZING WEED
AND SPORTS BETTING AND YOUR
POSITION ON ABORTION AND SOCIAL
ISSUES.
YOUR DAD WAS SOCIALLY A LIBERAL
LIBERTARIAN.
DO YOU AGREE WITH YOUR DAD?
>> LET'S START OFF WITH SPORTS
GAMBLING.
ANYTHING THAT WILL BRING REVENUE
INTO NEW YORK, I AM PRO THAT.
A LOT OF PEOPLE I KNOW GO TO NEW
JERSEY TO GAMBLE.
WHY ARE WE SACRIFICING THAT
REVENUE?
MARIJUANA THAT ANSWER WAS
DECIDED BY THE COURTS IN NEW
YORK.
IT IS LEGAL.
I DO NOT SUPPORT ANYBODY UNDER
THE AGE OF 18 FOLLOWING THE
SCIENCE AS REPUBLICANS ARE THE
PARTY OF SCIENCE THAT ENDS UP
USING MARIJUANA.
THEY ARE 3 TIMES MORE LIKELY TO
BE A HARD DRUG USER.
OVER THAT IS MUCH LESS.
THE OTHER TWO, I AM PRO-LIFE.
I DON'T KNOW IF WE HAVE THE
TIME.
I FORGOT THE 4th ONE.
I AM HAPPY TO GET INTO IT.
IT'S ABOUT ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
AND EDUCATION AND CRIME AND
REDUCING CRIME.
>> Sean: YOU ARE RUNNING ON THE
ECONOMY AND LAW AND ORDER AND
BRINGING IN REVENUE AND KEEPING
PEOPLE AND BUSINESSES HERE?
THAT'S WHAT I HEAR?
>> 100%.
THOSE APPLY TO ALL NEW YORKERS,
RED, WHITE, BLUE, ALL NEW
YORKERS ARE HAVING TERRIBLE
DIFFICULTY WITH ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND STAYING SAFE.
WE NEED TO MAKE NEW YORK THAT
CENTER OF THE WORLD AGAIN.
THE WAY WE BELIEVE IT WAS WHEN
WE BUILT THE CANAL CONNECTING
THE WORLD TO THE REST OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
I BELIEVE WE CAN DO IT AGAIN.
WE WILL DO IT.
>> Sean: LAST QUESTION DO YOU
SUPPORT FRACKING?
>> I DO.
ABSOLUTELY.
LOOK AT THE SOUTHERN TIER OF NEW
YORK.
YOU SEE WHERE THE VALUES ARE IN
PENNSYLVANIA AND WHERE THEY ARE
IN NEW YORK.
YOU TELL ME IF YOU SUPPORT
FRACKING.
>> Sean: I DO.
I WISH YOU ALL OF THE BEST.
NEW YORK NEE